hi there this is steve kaufman again uh
i'm going to do a little uh video here
on memory
this is a request from one of my viewers
wakako
um what do i consider to be the role of
memory in language learning
i'd like to start with an example that i
got from
oscar one of our link members in spain
we just had a conversation in spanish
and we talked about memory and he said
you know it's a bit like driving a car
when we drive a car
we do everything automatically because
we have
basically ingrained the the
the habits the patterns all the things
we need to do in order to drive a car we
do them automatically and we can't
remember
the last 10 minutes of our ride what we
did how we
you know signaled or turned or breaked
or changed gears or whatever it might be
and i think language learning is a bit
like that let me think of some other
things that relate to memory um i read
somewhere that they did a test with a
group of two groups of 20 language
learners
and the first
group was given a list of
whatever 20 30 words to learn
to study and the second group was not
given that list then they were asked to
read a text
and there was no difference in the
ability of these two groups to read
this text this was in the language that
they were learning and and so i mean
what was being pointed out in that study
was that being confronted with a lot of
things to remember
we don't necessarily remember them very
well
um
you know i have the experience when i
read sometimes for my russian study i'll
read a play by czechov
and at the beginning of the play they
introduce all of the
people who are in the play the general
and his daughter and so and so and his
wife and and of course as soon as i
start reading the play i can't remember
who's who
i know that when i look up words in a
dictionary uh no sooner do i look up the
words then i've forgotten what the
meaning was
so i think memory is not a very good
thing to rely on when speaking
sort of to review because it's a bit
like driving the car you have to be able
to produce these words and phrases
automatically on the fly
when we're driving i don't think we rely
on memory i don't think we try to
remember something we read in a manual
um
you know when i'm reading the play it's
only after i've read the play
quite a way through the play and i start
to become comfortable with the
characters in the play
occasionally referring back to the list
of characters that that i become
comfortable with who who is who in the
play
similarly with
with
words you know it's only when i've seen
the words in different contexts that
they start to stick
so
i think what we're dealing with in
language learning is more a matter of
establishing certain patterns in the
brain
so that initially things are new
um
primarily words and phrases and
gradually these become
patterns uh and the way the patterns are
formed is either
it's i think it's a combination of
of uh you know the brain
kind of uh
absorbing a lot of input and starting to
form its own patterns based on what it
hears
but i think the brain also
tries to rely on some logic that the
brain has
and one good example is
my favorite example of the third person
singular in the present tense of english
it's the only one that changes i go you
go he goes
uh he went they went uh you know but
he talks she talks so that always
changes
and yet i would think that amongst
even some very proficient speakers of
english even some native speakers of
english
he don't go
um
you know
people continue to make that mistake
because the the brain is saying
the pattern is that this should be the
same as all the others
and it's very difficult to remember by a
memory
that the third person singular is the
only one that's different
so i see language learning more as a
matter of
of gradually
getting used to something and allowing
the brain to form the necessary patterns
and this requires a lot of exposure